so left and right
you mentioned you're thinking of maybe
actually putting it down on paper or
something yeah i would like to because
what i would what i would like to point
out
again an in admiration of all the people
that i will then
try and have the gall to criticize this
look these are all geniuses
um lock genius adam smith
genius when he uses the notion that
we're bartering
creatures so he uses that reciprocation
idea
as the basis of his way of thinking
about things but that's not at the core
the murdering is not at the core of the
human nature it's not a well
he says it is he says we're
fundamentally bartering creatures
well that doesn't even make sense then
because then what how
how can do we then be autonomous
individuals
well because we're going to barter with
an ion on on for self
for ourselves self interest yeah but all
right so
but back to adam smith for a second lex
is like adam smith here's he's got the
invisible hand
and my conservative friends i'm like you
need to read
his books because he is a big fan of the
free market
and this is my other uh gripe
with folks who support just unbridled
markets adam smith understood that there
was a role
for government for two reasons one is is
that
just like locke people are not going to
behave with integrity
and he understood that one role of
government
is to maintain a proverbial
you know even playing field and
then the other thing smith said was that
there's some things that can't be done
well for a profit
and i believe he talked about education
and public health
and infrastructure as things that
are best done by governments
uh because you can't you can make a
profit but that doesn't mean that the
institutions themselves will be
maximally beneficial
yeah so i i would uh i'm just eager
to engage people by
saying let's start with our most
contemporary
understanding of human nature
which is that we are both selfish
and tend to cooperate
and we also can be heroically
helpful to folks in our own
tribe and
of course how you define one's tribe
becomes critically important but what
some people say is
look we let what would then be
what kind of political institutions and
what kind of economic
organization can we
think about to kind of hit that sweet
spot
and that that would be in my opinion uh
how do we maximize individual autonomy
in a way that fosters uh
creativity and innovation and the
self-regard that comes from creative
expression
while engaging our
more cooperative and reciprocal
tendencies in order to come up with a
system
that is potentially stable over time
because the other thing about
all capital-based systems is the
stability
is it fundamentally and unstable yeah
because it's based on infinite growth
and you know it's a positive feedback
loop to be silly
infinite growth is only good for
malignant cancer cells and compound
interest
otherwise uh you know we want to seek a
steady state
you